hey describe your comic-con experience
in a word and then set up sure in a word
sure wow I run the film what can we
expect a word oh my you're gonna go into
labor right um well it's it's really
close to the boat I think stephanie was
on set all the time which was awesome it
to feel like she's very much infused
into this one not that she isn't in all
of them i just i was able to talk to her
whenever I wanted you know just having
that having that was bringing for
obvious reasons I think people can
expect everything to finally come to
fruition and it's a really satisfying
experience or in the beginning is
actually the only time that I feel like
the only moment of calm in the entire in
the entire series they're happy and you
really don't know what could possibly go
wrong yeah there you go
Wow I don't know um I think poof
everything in Brazil was fun he's was
just like because I'd were novella very
rarely get a chance to be open and free
and sort of laughing and you know
they're touching each other normally
they're not like shaking Lee you know
did you get to keep the wedding dress